Have you ever been talking out loud and
while you're talking somebody says,
"Well, you know what I think is?" And
they just run right over you. What's the
first thing you think? You go, "Oh,
okay. I guess I'll stop talking now."
All of a sudden, they are controlling
the floor. Now they're dominating the
conversation and you really don't have
another window and you feel defeated.
What do you do when somebody is talking
over you? Well, there's a wrong way to
go about it and a right way to go about
it and I'm going to teach you both. Now,
if you listen to the rest of this
podcast, you are going to learn exactly
how to stop it when somebody tries to
dominate the conversation. You ready?
The wrong way to go about this is when
you start to yell and start to try and
get more attention to you. Somebody
starts interrupting you and the first
thing you say is, "Oh, excuse me. Am I
interrupting you?" Or, "Oh, is the end
of my sentence interrupt the beginning
of yours?" That kind of trying to be
cute language. That never works. Let me
tell you why it doesn't work. Because it
makes you look desperate. So whenever
somebody is dominating the conversation
and interrupts you, the worst thing you
can try and do is trying to take it back
from them when you try to out attention
them. That never works. It always puts
you in the weaker position. Why? Because
it looks like you're grasping for
control. That is the wrong way to go
about it. Instead, this is what I want
you to do when somebody tries to
dominate the conversation and talk over
you. You ready? Number one, I want you
to continue talking exactly as you were.
Keep the same volume, keep the same
tempo, keep the same pace, keep talking
just like you were. Do not stop. So when
everybody whenever that person at the
board meeting and wherever you are, they
start to try and catch in trying to talk
over you. Oh, I think what about and
they and they try and talk over you.
keep talking exactly where you are. This
works because it shows a discrepancy
between your very even kill controlled.
I'm going to continue talking no matter
what you say. Even if you interrupt me,
I am planted. I am grounded. I do not
care what you say. Whenever you keep
that same plane and they are just yeah,
barking way up here trying to get your
attention, trying to get everybody
else's attention, it shows that
discrepancy of you being very controlled
and them trying to grasp for control.
They're trying to get that attention
from everybody else while you are the
one staying calm and controlled. So
number one is continue to talk. Don't
stop talking. All right. Number two,
what I want you to do is resist the
temptation to raise your voice.
We always want to try and out talk the
other person whenever somebody starts
raising their voice. It's very natural.
It's very easy for us because we're
trying to kind of jump over them. We're
trying to It's like playing checkers.
You want to kind of jump over them. You
want to get on top of the conversation.
You want to dominate it in some way.
Anytime you do that, all it does is
escalate them to talk even more. That's
how shouting matches happen. Like if you
watch the news and you see the talking
heads on the news and the people that
are just fighting just arguing to argue
or if you watch like sports commentary
maybe on ESPN or something and and you
hear people taking two different
positions and somebody's interrupting
the other and somebody's interrupting
the other and they just start kind of
yelling back and forth. Who's listening?
Nobody. What do you do? You change a
channel. Nobody's learning anything.
Nobody can get anything from that
because it's just a power grab for
attention. So you're going to resist
that. All right. you're going to resist
that by continuing to keep your volume
exactly as it is. Why? Again, it shows
that discrepancy. That's what you want.
Number three, we're just swinging right
at it today. We're going we're going
straight for the throat. Anytime that
that person is trying to
dominate the conversation or interrupt
or continue talking and you don't feel
like you have a window, let's say we're
at a a board meeting and they're just
continue to talk and you don't feel like
you have a window into it. Here's the
key. use their name. People love to hear
their name. There's no sweeter sound
than the sound of their own name. So, if
they're talking and they're droning on
and they've kind of taken away the
conversation and gone on with their own
voice and with their own subject and
they think what they're saying is the
most important thing, I want you to use
their name. Use their name. So, let's
say it's me. Let's me I'm the big bad
guy right now and I am I just taken over
the conversation. you're talking to me
and I go, well, you know what I think is
you you ought to go, you know what you
should do? And I just start going on
away in my own views, opinions, and I'm
talking to an audience of one. If you
need to get my attention, what I want
you to say is, Jefferson,
that'll pop my head quick. Jefferson,
it's not raising your voice. You're not
saying it angry. You're not saying it
too um tender, almost too hesitant.
You're going to say it strong. You're
going to say it clear. Jefferson, if I
keep talking, say it again. Jefferson,
even if you need to raise the volume a
little bit, it's going to get my
attention. It's going to get the other
person's attention. They are going to
stop because they hear their name.
That's where that's the window. You've
now created the window into that
conversation where I want you to use the
phrase talk over.
Say something like, "It's not helpful
when you talk over me." Or, "I feel like
you're talking over me." Or, "I can't
hear you when you talk over me." I say
the very similar thing when somebody's
interrupting you, which in this case is
very related. I can't hear you when you
talk over me. Anytime you're using that
phrase, talk over, it's cluing them into
exactly what they're doing. Sometimes
people don't understand what they're
doing. They don't realize what they're
doing it. Maybe it's not on purpose, but
that's beside the point that the the
fact is they're doing it. So, you have
to take action. You can't just be quiet
and let them continue to talk and and
you and you feel less and then you feel
more dismissed. That kind of behavior is
something that you need to catch
immediately. You can't let it keep going
on. Why? Because you're otherwise
establishing a pattern of how they can
treat you, how they can talk to you,
that it's just a given that your opinion
does not matter as much as theirs. But
if you catch it, Jefferson,
I can't hear you when you talk over me.
It's not helpful for you to talk over
me. Jefferson, are you interested in my
thoughts or do you want to talk over me?
It depends how direct you need to be. I
You're the one who knows the personality
of the person that you're dealing with.
But that is exactly how I want you to
handle when somebody is talking over
you. I had something very similar when I
was a young associate at a law firm.
There was another associate of mine and
she had great ideas but she never felt
like she could really share them in the
meetings that we'd have and we'd have
other associate meetings. There would be
about 8 to 10 of us and she didn't feel
like she could really use her voice that
way. She was much more hesitant,
but still she had wonderful ideas. And
there are times where I would kind of
focus the conversation to tee it up so
she could talk. But at the same time, I
didn't always want to be the crutch that
goes, "Oh, she let me help guide the
conversation to her." So, I talked to
her about it. Said, "This is what I want
you to do." The next time David
starts to bounce over onto your
conversation. I want you to use his name
and watch what happens. Sure enough,
while she's given an idea of what she
thinks we should try and do for the
upcoming year, David immediately kind of
goes on the attack. You ever had
somebody who
in a meeting, specifically in a group,
that just wants to always feel like they
can go right for you. They can go right
for you every time that for some reason
you're you're their scapegoat. For some
reason, you're the outlet for them that
they as soon as you start talking, boom,
there they go. something about it
triggers you, triggers them. It was the
same way in this relationship. And so
she started talking. Boom. David goes
in. And first thing she had said, she
did was continued to talk exactly how
she was. What did it do? It didn't make
her look weak. It made him look weak
because looked like he was trying to get
in in the conversation and she was
totally ignoring it. Who we listened to?
We started listening to her, not him.
because it showed everybody in the room
what he was doing was not acceptable as
a group, as a community. He was now
making himself kind of as the outsider.
What she did next as he continues to
talk is she used his name. She used his
name and he snapped to attention. David,
you're talking over me. That's all she
said. You know what he did? Immediately
apologized. Why? Because he's looking
around and seeing everybody kind of
agrees. Nobody was fighting. Nobody was
sticking up for him. He's like, "Oh,
I'm, you know, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Go
ahead." Never again did he do that. So,
I want you to really think about this.
The next time that somebody is trying to
dominate a conversation, some somebody's
trying to speak over you, number one,
what I want you to do is to continue to
talk. Two, resist the temptation to
raise your voice to outtalk them because
that's a weaker position ultimately.
Three, what I want to make sure that you
do is realize the power of somebody's
name. So, if they keep on talking, use
their name. It is going to snap their
attention. It's going to make them stop
because they need to hear what comes
after their name, why you're using the
sweet sound of their name. That's your
window to be able to communicate exactly
what's happening into action. All right.
Sound good? I love this kind of stuff.
It's awesome. Quick, to the point. You
can do it. I know that you can. Why
would you write a book about
communication and argue less, talk more,
but then really rule one is don't win.
Is that more of a mindset thing? Is that
what you mean when I approach a
conversation with somebody or is that
you literally mean that don't try to win
an argument?
>> I literally mean that. If you go into it
always just wanting to win the argument,
you will lose something else that is far
more valuable every time. when I'm
arguing in front of a judge uh and the
other side's arguing again there's case
law there's a statute there's a a law
that is applying to this and they just I
might have more precedent than the other
person and they can't compete against
that it doesn't mean that their argument
wasn't any better but you get into
especially in the courtroom this feeling
of well I have to win a lot of trials
listen if you haven't lost trials you
haven't tried enough trials that's just
the way it goes if you want to spot
somebody who's inexperienced they
haven't lost enough. Um, but the mindset
to it is much more impactful in every
listener's world right now. That if you
find that every book you read, every
blog that you see is something that how
to win every argument, it's it's lying
to you. Because what you're going to do
when you have that mentality is you're
going to lose the relationship. You're
going to lose their respect. They're
going to close themselves off from you.
You're going to be less approachable.
You're gonna lose quality of your
reputation if all you seek to do is win
every argument.
>> What if you're with someone who does try
to do that? So, let's start out. His
content, you guys, is so specific is
what I like about it. It's not just
general principles. There's actually
real phrasiology, real words where
perhaps you are the secondary person is
what I would call it. So you could be
husband and wife, boyfriend, girlfriend,
friend, boss, and person they supervise,
but one has sort of asserted the
superior position in a conversation, if
that makes sense. Almost like they're
always teaching you a lesson or they're
in the control position. Is there a way
to sort of wrestle's the wrong word, but
reestablish pecking order or at least
equality in a convers? You know what I
mean when I say that? that you have
people that in your life that talk to
you as if they're the expert on
everything, you're not. They're in
charge, you're not. They're picking the
restaurant, you're not.
>> Is there a way when someone has that
dynamic with you to change that dynamic?
I I started with one of the hard
questions first because I think more
people find themselves invisible pecking
order conversations almost than maybe
they realize.
>> Let's split the dynamic, too. Let's say
it's if it's one-on-one, much harder
because
th this person has constructed their
whole identity most likely to this
facade. If it is, let's say you're in a
meeting and that person is trying to
establish the pecking order. The other
people will change the dynamic for you.
You don't have to push back. You just
can't be pushed over. Let's say
one-on-one with this conversation with
somebody who feels like they're more
dominant. Biggest thing you're going to
do is just not be pushed over. Meaning
you're not going to continue to chase
everything that they say. You're not
going to push back cuz they're looking
for that threat. We call it water off a
duck's back where anything that somebody
says, you can just say, "Okay, noted. I
got it. No, if I have any questions,
I'll ask." This ability to kind of be in
the in the pocket in your communication.
The temptation is we want to compete
with them. Oh, you just went skydiving.
Oh, that's great. I just went twice. Oh,
you know, uh, Ed, Ed's great. Yeah, you
need to. and they start to compete with
one another of how many names they can
drop, uh, how many experiences they can
share. But all that does is show more
and tells more about their insecurity
than it does really about any kind of
true substance. Let's say, let's just
use the word alphas or the people that
are very confident in the communication,
the conversation typically say much
less. You've been in those meetings
where the person who always has their
two cents, the person who always has
something to say is the person most
likely the least removed from the actual
true conversation of what's happening.
They have to tell you so much so that
you can know how smart they are. The
real top dog is the person that's the
most quiet. And when that person speaks,
everybody's quiet and everybody listens.
So insecurities are very loud.
Confidence is very quiet. You say that
about leaders too. It struck me where
you said actually great leaders learn to
say more with literally fewer words than
the non-leer. You believe that's one of
the traits of a great communicator of a
leader. Correct.
>> Correct. Good leaders respond in
conversation. Great leaders leave room
for conversation. So when there is this
mentality that the leader has to say,
I'm captain of this ship and everybody
should know it. Oh, who do you think
you're talking to? And they need to
correct and and drive traffic and go go.
The best leaders are ones that they
don't have to prove everything. Insecure
people feel like they have to prove.
They have to say a whole lot just so you
believe that they're smart. Confident
people know that. Great leaders already
know that. They're the ones that have
this calm energy. In my view, the the
best leaders have a calm energy about
them when they're on the floor of
whatever is happening instead of this
erratic, you know, what's going on?
Okay, we need to do this and and they
start shouting and getting mad and
yelling at people versus the person who
comes on the floor and goes, okay, what
do we need to do next? What's happening
next? Instead of blame, it's where are
we moving forward? So, driving the
conversation in a way that sets
authority. People are looking for
anchors in conversation. Same thing in
their everyday business. Employees,
supervisors, whoever it is, they're
looking for the anchors in their
organization and same in everyday
conversation. So, you have to find the
way to be confident enough to be the
anchor. If you feel like you lose
control in conversation more than you
keep it, this episode is for you. I'm
making this specifically for you. But
what I'm going to teach you if you
listen to this episode is exactly how to
make sure that that shift of power
returns back to you. I'm going to make
it short. I'm going to make it sweet and
it's going to work. You ready?
Controlling conversation is a funny
thing. You don't know how to describe
it, but you know when you don't have it,
you know when you could get it. It's in
that time that the usually in the
silence of the conversation that as
things are going momentum starts to
shift the other way. It starts to swing
the other way and it feels like
everything around you is kind of
dissolving.
Think of a time most recently in your
life where you felt the power dynamic
shift. Maybe it's somebody who's a
superior. Maybe it's somebody who
intimidates you. Maybe it's somebody you
don't like. Or maybe it's somebody you
love and it still feels like you don't
have something inside of you that's able
to keep what's yours and instead you
feel like you're giving it all away.
Your needs, your wants, your your power,
your control, whatever it is, your
truth. This episode is going to teach
you exactly what to do. So, how do we do
that? Number one, you're going to use
questions
that force a reset in the conversation.
Now, what do I mean by that? Think of
like your laptop or your phone. You you
have a a button typically that has like
a forced reset. It doesn't matter what's
happening. Maybe you're on your phone
and it it freezes or your laptop and it
freezes. What do you have to do? You
have to kind of like hold the power
button down until it eventually what?
Shuts off and [snorts] then you're able
to click it again and force restart it.
It's not doing it on its own. You are
having to inject something into it.
That's what these questions do. These
are intelligent questions. These are not
just the basic ones. These are questions
that call for reflection in the
conversation that make people think. And
that alone is going to stop the
momentum, stop the shift, momentum, the
power that's going away from you and
bring that control back to you in a way
or at least at the very least level the
playing field. You say, Jefferson, what
do these questions sound like? I'm going
to tell you. These are questions that
sound like, "Are you against us talking
at a normal tone? Are you against us
talking about this calmly?
Are you against us talking about this
openly?
Is it unreasonable for me to ask you to
lower your voice? Is it unreasonable for
me to assume that what I tell you can be
kept in confidence?"
Or maybe it's I need to know where we're
going in this conversation. Can you help
explain to me where we're going in this
conversation? Where is this conversation
going? So, these are three key words
that I really picked up on that I'm I'm
wanting you to pick up on is one, we are
using the the natural mind to think in
the negatives. Meaning, if somebody asks
you to do something, typically you want
to say no. Think of when you're kids. I
if I ask my daughter when she was two to
go do something, the first thing she'd
say is no. We have the same exact thing.
It doesn't go away. We just have
different filters as we age. Well, if I
were to say, are you against us talking
about this calmly?
The first thing they're going to want to
respond with is no.
Are you against? No, I'm not against
that. Then they will naturally lower it.
Who's going to say yes, I'm against
talking calmly? So, you use that to your
advantage. It makes them think it's if I
if I'm going to say, are you are you
against us talking about this in a way
that's helpful? You hear how it makes
you almost have to work through it
backwards? It takes some time, even
though it sounds simple for somebody to
hear it, reverse engineer it. That's the
time frame that you want. All right?
That's levels the playing field. That's
the forced reset. That moment where
people have to think and you get to now
ask a question and they are now
acquiescing to what you've asked for. Is
it unreasonable? Most people will again
say no to things. If I were to say, "Is
it reasonable to ask you to stop
yelling?" You know what's going to
happen? They're going to say, "No, it's
not reasonable. You You know how upset I
am right now?" But if I were to say, "Is
it unreasonable for me to ask you to
lower your voice?"
They're not going to say, "Yes, it is."
They'll most likely say, "No." Why?
Because no is easier to say. In that
moment where they reverse engineer the
question, that's the shift of momentum.
I need you to tell me where we're going
in this conversation. Help me understand
where we're going.
It's easy. It's it's the I am wanting to
know where's the deadline. Where's the
the finish line? Not the deadline, the
finish line. Where do we go there? All
that's doing is making them think, hey,
what am I talking about this for? What
am I talking about this for? It's it's
jumping to that end. You are creating
that moment where they have to pause.
They respond to your question, which
levels the playing field because that
time stops the momentum. It is like
icing the kicker in football. If you
watch American football, you know that a
lot of times they will if if or even in
basketball, lots of different sports
when things are going a team's way and
especially in basketball and somebody is
they're scoring a lot, the other team
will typically call a timeout. Let's
stop the momentum. They're they're
getting too much going on. That's
exactly what these questions do. Exactly
what these questions do. and it gives
you the control back in the
conversation. Number two, aside from
intelligent questions that are making
them stop, what I want you to think of
is times where you can use phrases that
are going to call moments of more
reflection for the other person.
Why? Because it is giving you that
control back. There's not a statement I
can tell you that's going to just force
the control there. Questions do it.
Questions do it. My favorite, and if you
listen to this podcast, you know, is the
phrase, "Did you mean?" Did you mean for
that to sound dismissive? Did you mean
for that to sound a little manipulative?
Did you mean for that to embarrass me or
offend me? The did you mean questions,
what they do is they put a big spotlight
on the other person's behavior and it
makes them have to think about what
their motive was. What was my intent in
asking this? What was my motive in
asking this? And usually if it's a a
truly negative motive, like did you say
that to embarrass me? It forces them to
now like they they feel angst. They they
they don't like that they got heartburn.
Now they got called out. They got called
out. And now what they have to do is
shift it back. They have to uh stop.
They have to hedge. They have to put on
the brakes and realize, whoa, whoa,
whoa. I'm I'm getting called out right
here. I don't like that. I'm going to
start looking bad. I don't want that. So
they'll they'll turn that trajectory.
And what they do is they lower and now
you're more balanced in the
conversations. Did you mean number
three? One of my favorite things to do
in conversations, particularly when it
feels like somebody else is trying to
take control in the conversation, I will
ask the question, are we on equal
footing?
It could be something very similar to
that. Is this a conversation where we're
balanced?
I talk about things that are up and
down. I want to make sure that we're
walking side by side. And usually I'll
ask that question. Are we walking side
by side right now? I want to make sure
I'm walking alongside you in this
conversation. Whenever you're using
words that call balance, even the
imagery of balanced,
are we are we side by side here? Are we
balanced? Are we on the same plane? Are
we on the same footing? You can think of
a thousand other ways to say it. What
they do, these phrases, these questions
that make the other person kind of slow
down. They make them slow down in the
conversation. That's what you want. And
that's what's going to return the
control back to you. There's nothing you
can say that's going to say, "Hey, I
want control back in this conversation."
That's not going to happen. It's a
statement. What it does is it makes you
look like you are
uh vain. It makes you look like you're
aggressive. It makes you look like you
are desperate. It makes you desperate is
the best word for it. It It makes you
look like you're already lost it, right?
Makes you look like you've already lost
it. One of the best of the ways I I can
think of rather than trying to grasp for
that attention.
Control is is also found in the silence.
So many times in conversation,
the most powerful move you can make is
no move at all. Not saying anything. If
you want to return conversational power
back to you, often silence
and pauses are the best thing that's
going to do that. Pauses.
If you if somebody else is on a roll,
you can call your own timeout. If they
are being and when I say on a roll,
maybe they are being way too aggressive
with you, then what you say is, "I need
to come back to this conversation when
I'm in a better place.
I'll come back to this conversation when
I'm ready. I can tell I'm not in a good
I'm not myself right now. I can tell I'm
not ready for this conversation. This is
not a conversation that I need to be in
right now.
Pause it. Time it. Why did I say that?
Don't say it like that. Take a time out.
Pause the conversation. And what you do
is now the nerves settle. What happens
is you're able to now look like you're
the one that's in control of the
conversation because you're not
responding emotionally. You're not
saying things you don't mean. You're not
trying to say the yeah, buts, but but
what about you're not trying to throw
daggers and add these little paper cuts
to the conversation that don't do
anything. Control is also very much
found in the silence and taking breaks.
And what's that? that that is you
calling your shot of when and you when
you will not have conversation. Those
three tips right there alone. See, I
told you short and sweet rolled right
into it. That's exactly what's going to
help you the next time you feel like
you're losing power in a conversation.
So, what do we talk about? Number one,
using intelligent questions. Are you
against? Is it unreasonable? Show me
where we're going. Anything related to
that. using the the negatives that's
going to get somebody to have to think
more reflectively about the conversation
and stop the momentum. Two, we're going
to use questions that talk about the
intent and motive. That's going to again
reflect that and make them pause. Three,
largely I want to go right into that
silence. That's number three. Silence is
so often the very thing that will stop
the m momentum, bring control back
because you are choosing your words when
you want them and what you want to say.
That's how you keep control. One of the
top three communication strategies of
this year is saying less.
Saying less. So many of you said, "I
have a problem overexlaining.
I say too many words." And then after
the conversation, I am kicking myself
because I just couldn't stop talking. I
couldn't stop talking. Hey, first off, I
want you to understand there's nothing
wrong with that. You're normal. You're
just fine. Why does it happen?
Generally, it happens because of a deep
insecurity,
of feeling like you're not being
believed.
My guess is it has to do with things
that happened in your past as a child of
feeling like you had to talk more to be
listened to. You had to talk more to
feel believed. You had to talk more to
feel competent. And that you always
needed to overexlain in order for you to
feel okay. And that's continued to
become a pattern in your life. That is
perfectly okay. It can be changed. We
can do all kinds of techniques, but I
want you to understand just because you
talk a lot, nothing wrong with you. All
right? I was a kid that always talked a
lot. I know lots of people who talk a
lot. It matters when the moment matters.
If you're overexlaining when you need to
say less, then it's always going to to
hurt in some way. Because if you're in a
conflict with somebody and you start
overexlaining and you keep on talking,
what happens is the other person loses
the point because instead of trying to
listen to the point you're trying to
make, they start getting defensive about
the additional things you're adding. So
you might try to be recalling a story of
like, well, you did this and I did this
and then you just start talking. You're
not getting to the point. And the other
person goes, well, that's not how I
would put it. Well, that's feels a
little harsh. and they start getting
more defensive because you're just
saying surplus information, things that
are not relevant to the point and maybe
even if they are relevant, they are not
helpful. What's the mindset that I want
you to have? This is something that
resonated so much with many of you and
it is instead of being a waterfall, be a
well rather than feeling like you have
to gush information and give them way
too much and so much so that the message
just gets swept away. a waterfall of
information, more than they can possibly
even hold at that moment where it's
going to confuse them. It's going to
overwhelm them. Be a well. All right. A
well is very confident in the depth of
its knowledge. A well is always going to
give you exactly what you came there to
get.
So if somebody needs something from you,
you're going to answer concisely. You're
going to say less. And if they have more
questions, they're going to ask you.
This is the time, this is the season of
your life that you're going to trust
that if somebody needs something, they
will ask. You're not going to just
selflessly give and people please and
try to overexlain because that's not
helping them. You're trying to do it to
help yourself. All right? You're trying
to soothe yourself in that moment. We're
going to create the habit of saying
exactly what we need to say. So, here's
a test. All right? Here's a test. And I
and I do this for companies all the
time. If you can't say it in three
sentences, you need to rethink it before
you send that text, that email. If you
cannot explain, if you cannot describe
how you feel and what's going on in
three sentences or less, you need to
redo it. I'm not saying this is a hard
and fast rule. I'm saying it's it's a
pretty good parameter of a gauge of am I
over explaining because we know what
it's like when you send let's say you're
in a a text argument. Ever been in a
text argument with your spouse or
somebody in relationship with and or
maybe a friend and what do we do? We
write like a paragraph, a whole
paragraph of text and you send it. Do
they even really respond to the point
you're making? No. They chose to pick
off something else that you said and
they decided to start off a a fight
about that. Why? Because you gave too
much. You gave too much. You need to be
concise. So when you say less words, you
sound more confident. You sound more
assertive.
Less is more. All right?
Silence meaning me choosing not to say
anything. Silence can never be misqued.
Silence can never be misqued. When I am
saying less words, it means I'm choosing
my words. So if somebody is of that type
when they're just asked a question and
they just start talking right away, what
can they do to take time and space for
themselves to pause and just think and
sort through their ideas? What they need
to do is make their breath the first
word that they say. So rather than going
straight into the conversation, rather
than just start with the the word vomit,
the let me spill out my ideas, if you
just take a breath
right before you respond,
what it's doing is not only regulating
your body, you know, making sure you're
more aware and in control of your
emotions. It is signaling to the other
person that what I'm about to say has
been thought about, has been
acknowledged. There's a difference of
you asking me a question, hey Jefferson,
how was your day? And I went, it was
good. It was good, Chris. It was fine.
It was fine. It was a good day. Doesn't
really sound like I really thought about
it, but if you asked me, hey Jefferson,
how was your day? And I went,
you know, Chris, it was good. It was a
good day. Ups and downs, but it was
good. Which one of those sounds like I
actually acknowledged what you said,
really thought about it, and and in
exchange you actually want to hear what
I'm about to say more? Like same thing
with in an interview. That's probably
one of the top things I talk about with
friends that are going into an interview
and they're like, "Hey, what should I
do?" It's like the slower you answer the
question, the better the interview will
be. They ask you a question and you just
immediately try to it has to be as fast
as possible. That's the opposite. What
you are need needing to exude in that
moment is I can take stressful moments
including the interview that I'm in
and be able to regulate myself and show
you that I'm not somebody who runs in
conversation. I walk in it. And whenever
you slow yourself down, they're going to
find that what you're saying is they're
going to even feel that what you're
saying is more thought out and more
intentional than if it's just off the
cuff.
To the best of your ability to recall,
when do you first remember this being a
conscious thought or effort from your
part?
>> I started teaching clients this very
early on in my really as a first year
associate. Uh I was at a law firm that
was the type that you know I wasn't
behind a lot of partners. It was like
these are your clients. You either sink
or swim get after it. So you really go
to your first trial, your first year by
yourself. And I can remember training
some of the first people
on they get so nervous before their
deposition. There's cameras, there's
other people. And I'm teaching them,
okay, instead of just going right into
it, they ask you a question. Instead of
just having an immediate response, take
a minute. And some I would say, I want
you to just count one Mississippi.
That's it. Just one. And I mean, I did
all kinds of things to try and get them
to remember it. And so then what I would
do is I would put on the hat of being
the opposing attorney and I'd say,
"Okay, Chris, you know, you understand
that you're here today. Is that ain't
that true?" And I would start to kind of
pressure them and get them all kind of
worked up. And I'd say, "Okay, this is
the moment. This is where count just in
your head, one Mississippi.
Okay, now answer." Instead of feeling
like you're in their time frame, in
their time space, you're controlling it.
You're saying, "Nope, I'm the one that's
driving in my lane. and you can't do
anything about it. So, it's really it's
like teaching defensive driving verbally
how to do that. Now, on the flip end of
that is I I'm a fifth generation trial
attorney. All the men in my attorney
family are attorneys, women, too. And my
dad is this way. I could come to my dad
with an issue and I'd say, "Oh, that we
got this. We have this problem." And
he'd go,
"Yep, that's a problem." You know what I
mean? Like that. who's just [laughter]
always very very very keel. And so I
would be I would be like, "Oh my gosh,
Dad, they're going to be they're but
they're going to be really upset." And
he would take a beat and say, "Yep, I
guess they'll be upset." That was just
his type of demeanor.
>> And so, of course, it's just genetics
mirroring that my entire life. Um, yeah,
he was he would always exude the the run
or the walk don't run kind of mentality.
>> I can feel my energy change just by the
way that you were changing your tone and
the pace in which you were talking.
This is just goes to to the point of
like how much the tone and the way that
you deliver the words matter sometimes
even more than the words because when
you're putting on that like um that mock
trial thing with the opposing council
saying so what were you I just felt like
whoa
>> like I'm going to say something probably
not that smart probably something that's
going to incriminate myself right then.
>> Right. Right. Even if you don't mean to.
>> Yeah. I I just felt it right away
because your baseline is so calm,
reassuring, and and just gentle, and
inviting that the minute that you
switched that up, I could feel it
immediately.
>> I'm sure I'm not the only one. If you're
listening to this, just let us know that
I'm not the only person who felt that.
>> Right. Right. Right. Well, the thing is
anybody can do it, Chris. It's I mean,
it's more natural to me because this is
how I was raised. This is the household
I I I was in. I mean, I was raised on on
the Socratic method and I'd come with
the problems and my dad would say,
"Well, what do you think they would say
about that?" You know, like he would
always put it in the position of the the
other person and slow me down. But like
if you're listening right now, if you
want to sound more confident, more
respected in your communication and more
even
more serious, more warm, whatever it is,
all you need to do is slow down your
words and lower your volume. It makes a
huge impact. If you are with somebody
who's always loud and very aggressive,
do you want to do more of what they say
or less? So like compare it to to this.
If I were to say, "Look, Chris, I
already told you I'm not I'm I'm not
going to do that versus
Chris already told you I'm not going to
do that."
Now, which one of those
is would say somebody who sounds more
grounded, somebody who sounds more
balanced, somebody who sounds more
composed, somebody really you don't want
to mess with? It's actually the person
who sounds less emotional, the person
who sounds less aggressive,
>> who says, "Oh, no. This is not somebody
I want to mess with." And it's I'm
saying the same thing, but the
connotation, the feeling is very, very
different.
>> Okay. You say it, I feel it, I live it.
There's so many people who will hear
this and say like, gosh, it just I can't
figure it out. Now, you must have worked
with some some clients in in the
courtroom where you're like, okay, just
take a breath or go real slow and then
you see them on the stand and they're
like,
>> that's got to happen, right?
>> Oh, yeah. It'll happen all the time.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And when you're on break, do you
how do you redirect? How do you get them
in that pocket again?
>> Yeah. So, you kind of have to do it
without telling them about it. Like I
have
>> um for example, I had this guy once
who
um you know, he had read some stuff on
Google and he's like, "Oh, no. You know,
I read you need to be, you know, really
short with your answers." I like, "Oh,
that's that's all great." And they on
textbook, they think they got it all
worked out. And despite all of my
preparation with them, they got we had I
had them go right into the deposition.
He started out great. And it it took no
no time at all. Chris, he was starting
to step on the other attorney's
questions. So before the attorney was
actually an finished with their
question, he's already stepping on it
with their answer. So he the question
was something like, you know, now you
went that day. You first drove to your
cousins and you'd be like house. Yep. I
went to their house. So he's stepping on
the the words which you don't want to do
because in terms of the reason why
there's a court reporter is because
everything's written down. So on paper
it doesn't look good. It's what they
would say it's a messy record because
you have these insertions into instead
of a full question a full answer. And he
kept doing it and I was like you know
better. And so in my head I'm like all
right this next question I'm going to
pull him out. So sure enough he answers
the last question stepped on it again.
And I say, "Okay, let's take a we're
just going to take a five-minute break.
Let's just take a little break. You want
to stand up for a second?" He's like,
"Yeah, that's fine." And so we get out
of the room and I just say, "Hey, just
walk with me." And so I'm unrolling a
peppermint while I'm doing it, just
action, acting super nonchalant. I pop
it in my mouth. I'm like, "You just sit
right here." We sit down and I say, "So,
um, how old are your kids again?" And he
was like, "Ah, yeah, you know, seven.
Seven and eight." I was like, "Oh,
that's that's great. That's great. Ages.
What? What? What did y'all uh what did
y'all do the last week? And all of a
sudden, he starts to like calm down.
He's like, "Oh, we uh we went to um a
movie." I was like, "What movie?" He's
like, "It's the movie with the you know
the talking animals." I think it was
like um Madagascar, you know. Uh
something like that. Madagascar 2. I was
like, "Oh, that's that's great." I was
like, "Was it good?" And he stops and he
slows down and he goes, "Yeah, I mean it
was good. You know, it was a cute
movie." And I said, 'Good. All right.
You see what we're doing here? He goes,
"Yeah." I said, "That's exactly what
you're going to do in there." I said,
"We're going to slow it down." He goes,
"Ah, I'm stepping on it, aren't I?" I
said, "Yep, that's exactly what you're
doing." All right, so let's let's go
back and treat it just like you're
you're talking to me right here. And
sure enough, he went right back. He's
like he had to hear it. He had to feel
it
>> for me to make him click rather than me
pulling him out and going, "Hey, stop
>> stepping on the question and get let him
get it all out." Okay, that's not going
to do it. But by showing the example,
making them feel like it was or just
right there, keeping it in the pocket. I
was like, let's let's stay right in this
momentum. You feel this? And he was
like, yeah, I feel that. Okay, let's
stay right here. So, I use that phrase
in the pocket a whole lot with him.
>> Okay, this is excellent. Very
interesting how you took it to a very
conversational level where there's
nothing for him to be nervous about.
>> Yeah. and so that he can be a better
performer in the courtroom because there
shouldn't be a difference between this
style of talking versus like when you're
getting grilled by the other attorney.
And I find that in sales,
we can have a normal conversation,
everything's going great, but when
they're on a call with a client, they
get all high pitch, they get really
nervous and anxious, and they start
start talking really fast. They start
doing performative things that they
normally just don't do. So are we
talking there's this universal concept
about communication like how you talk to
a really good friend is how you should
talk everywhere
in my opinion yes. Now I would say
there's a difference in of course
context and environment. I'm not going
to talk to a prospective client the same
way I'm going to talk to my grandmother,
you know, or or or my best friend or my
dad. There's casual situations where
when you and I are in sweatpants and
drinking coffee talking about life, it's
not the same. So, but I would say the
premise holds true that you generally
want everybody to feel very comfortable
around you. Even when you're public
speaking, one of the best compliments
you can get is you seem so comfortable
up there. Yeah. Because when you
understand that I don't have anything to
prove. I'm just telling you what I know.
I can be excited about what I have to
share. And when I get excited about the
message of what I'm giving,
then I can channel that excitement into
how it's going to benefit everybody
else. And that that's a that's a
wonderful thing to be generous with your
words and generous with your message.
Now, if somebody is grilling you in a
deposition type of setting, it is it is
different. It just it's understanding
that you can't make me say anything I
don't want to say and you can't make me
talk any faster than I'm going to
respond. So when I understand that I'm
the one that has control of the steering
wheel at all times, it's a very
confident mindset. It's a gamechanging
type of concept. When you understand
that you you say something to me, I can
choose not to say anything at all.
That's a pretty powerful thing. People
feel like you always have to have a
response. It's not true. So when you're
talking in front of people, even in that
sales context,
if you can't just be you, like we have
such a six sense of knowing when
somebody's being fake, let me tell you
what, a jury knows immediately, Chris,
if somebody's being fake. And they will
destroy them. They will pour their whole
case out if they feel like they're being
fake. I can't tell you how many times
I've seen a jury totally turn on
somebody's case if they thought that
they were being somebody that they're
not. Like you just meet somebody and go
there's something about them that
doesn't it's just this six sense that we
have. I think it's very
um I don't I I'm not sure if it's just
the DNA of our cavemanlike abilities to
go, "No, something doesn't smell right
about this. I'm not sure what it is, but
something's not." And and it's even
people who try too hard, right? They're
like, "No,
>> they're trying too hard." Like, what
does that even mean? They're they're
being somebody that they're not. Ever
had somebody try to really make you like
them? You're like, it makes you it's
it's a turnoff. Now you definitely don't
like them. Why? because they're trying
too hard to be liked. I don't They're
being somebody that they're not. Uh if a
witness on the stand is faking sympathy,
like trying to gain sympathy. Let's say
they kind of act, you can tell they're
being fake emotional about it. They
really don't mean it. Or a jury will
just go, "Nope, we don't trust you. No
credibility. I think you're faking it."
And it's it's king's eggs every time.
So, what are the three power moves in
conversations
that
really set you up for success in any
conversation?
>> Number one is silence, just nothing. So,
if somebody were to say something that's
snarky,
the best move is to say nothing. You
just kind of sit back and you look
around or you look up, you look off.
I'm telling you, nine times out of 10,
they can't take it.
>> Really,
>> they can't take that silence because
then
then it's spread out. You've just
exposed instead of you covering it up
with something else that says, "Excuse
me, did what did you say?"
>> You're just leaving it open.
>> Kind of like that. That the best foot
you're going to put out right now? That
one.
>> You go that the one we're going to
choose. And if you just let that silence
sit there often times and you probably
heard this they go I shouldn't have said
that. You you got to give them that
chance.
>> That's number one.
>> Yeah. Number one is you got you got to
give him a chance of of that silence.
Number two acknowledge that it could be
without acknowledging that it is. And
you say example of saying well maybe so
maybe you're right.
>> Not say you're right.
>> No
>> but maybe you are.
>> Maybe maybe you're right. But it's that
piece of humility that says well maybe
you're right.
>> I had a guy once who said uh I was
deposing him and you know all these all
you lawyers worst things that ever
happened to America kind of talk and I
said well maybe you're right but today
just going to be a conversation between
us.
>> Is it okay if you're just talking to
Jefferson? And he said yeah I can do
that.
>> Wow. And so it's that ability to just
well maybe so but I could have I could
have gotten really defensive with him. I
could have I could have chosen to taken
that personally instead just dropped it.
Uh the other power other power move is
to hold off on the timing.
So when you are mad that's generally not
the best time to do it. when like when
when you know you've done something
wrong and you want somebody to be mad at
you to like fight me please like I know
I've done something wrong I let's let's
have this out we'll talk about this you
you want to talk about this at noon
let's talk about
>> let's put it in the calendar for
tomorrow
>> you got it well I'm okay it's I'm glad
I'm glad you said that well then you
know I don't really have my thoughts
together on that but
>> why don't we kind of talk about that at
noon tomorrow. What do you think? Now
they're like, "Oh my god, like I just I
just said something that I shouldn't
have said." [laughter]
But that's that's a much better way of
of uh of handling it because at that
point, you have not lost any confidence.
You have not lost your credibility.
You just you've maintained that you're
the one in control at all times. And I'm
telling you, the key is just starting
with your breath
>> and choosing to be quiet,
>> right?
If you were if you were to say something
to me and I responded right away, like
if you were to say, um, I don't know, do
you do you, um, do you enjoy matcha tea?
I go, no. Versus me thinking,
>> no.
>> Like there's just a different
connotation to it when you think about
it.
>> Yeah. Um about 14 years ago,
um
someone gave me a
a line that became one of the most
powerful uses of language
over the last 14 years to help me get
almost anything I want or more of what I
already have.
And I use it all the time. When I go
uh order a coffee, I use it. When I go
to a hotel and try to get an upgrade, I
use it. When I'm working with uh
partners and collaborators, I use it.
And the line is, what's the chance?
What's the chance you can give me a
discount on this? What's the chance you
can give me an upgrade in this hotel
room?
>> What's the chance you can give me in
first class?
>> Yeah. What's the chance we can
collaborate in a bigger way?
>> Yeah.
>> What's the chance you can go a little
more on this?
And
I've used that over and over again
because it continues to work. And I
almost use it as a game daily. Like
>> any store I go into, I'm just like,
>> what's the chance you got 10% off on
this?
>> Yeah.
>> Just to see if you can make something
happen.
>> Cuz if you don't ask, you're not going
to get it.
>> Right.
>> And um it's just like a way to be
playful. It's a way to like see can I
enroll someone in something that I maybe
I shouldn't be getting but would I get?
>> Yes.
>> And it often works where the unexpected
happens. Is there another
line of communication that you use maybe
even unknowingly that you use
consistently that seems to
>> just help you enroll people in more of
what you want?
So I do I absolutely use the what's the
chance really?
>> Yeah. So I I will use that when it feels
like a like a stalemate between the
other attorney
>> and look what's the chance that your
client's going to be able to do
>> X Y and Z.
Also I will try to separate the attorney
from the client. same way I do with like
the reception clerk versus the hotel. I
I I make sure that I acknowledge them as
the person because I acknowledge their
struggle of what they're going through,
>> right?
>> And so if I talk to the attorney of
look, I can only imagine, you know, all
the updates you're you're having to do
or all the work you're putting through.
I I know that this is how you're doing
the best thing you can for your client.
I mean, between me and you, what what
what's the chance that we can do X, Y,
and Z? or if I were to do or if I were
to say or if my client were if I were to
encourage my client to do this,
is that something that I should do?
And it gives them something to think
about,
>> right?
>> The same way like at a let's say at a
hotel or something like that, I I can
only imagine you just spend how how
long's your shift?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. 7 hours. Oh my gosh. Yeah. That's
going to be And so you just Yeah. You
kind of create that connection with them
that says I'm talking to you
individually as a person rather than
seeing you as the whole then because
that's who they are.
>> Yeah. Exactly. That's powerful. You have
these um powerful life lessons, okay, in
the book for our communication. I want
to go through some of them. Now, some of
them you've you kind of touched on
already, but I I'd love to go through
some of these bit by bit to really give
practical
takehomes for people. Okay. Now one of
the lessons is that silence is power.
Right? Why?
It is the one thing that someone cannot
throw back in your face. [snorts]
It silence can never be misqued.
Silence is not something that you can
somebody can create anything out of so
to speak. Silence gives you the power to
choose
that gives you options. Is this somebody
I want to talk to? Is this something I
want to respond to? Is this something
that's worth my time? Is this person
worth my time? It it the first thing to
know about standing up for yourself is
knowing, is this person worth getting
out of my chair for? It is silence that
puts things on pause because you can't
make me say anything I don't want to
say. I can physically grab you and I can
physically manipulate you but I cannot
do that with your words. I cannot force
you to say something without forcing you
physically. Silence is your tool that
you can have and it's wonderful in the
sense of you use it for difficult
conversations. You use it for meaningful
conversations. Let's say you're sharing
something with me that's very deep and
you've had a very hard day. I don't need
to fix it. I just need to sit with you.
>> Yeah.
>> And in that silence, holding that what
the the therapy world would say, holding
that space for you, just sitting in here
with you. I don't have to say anything,
but at the same time, I'm saying
everything.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, let's say you're saying something
mean to me and you say something that
really hurts and rather than responding,
I just say nothing. Now, that sends
another message. That's another option
that I get to have. And now you have to
hear those words echo back and you have
to do something with it. That's why
silence is such a powerful tool.
>> Could it be deemed as being aggressive
if we use silence?
>> You can weaponize it. Yeah. So you could
that turns into stonewalling. That turns
into people ghosting for no reason. Yes.
Stonewalling in my opinion is weaponized
silence. You are doing it as a as a
punishment. It's punitive. It's a sense
of control. If you try to I'm not
talking about the grey rock type of
stuff where it's you have to protect
yourself. I'm talking you're some you're
dealing with somebody who's a tox toxic
personality and they just go silent on
you in as a term of punishment. They
want you to come graveling back. Not
until you say, "Oh, I'm so sorry. Can
you please come back to me?" Will they,
you know, graciously in their mercy go,
"Yes, I guess you can talk to me again."
So, there is absolutely a way to be
taken it too far as with anything. Yeah,
it kind of sort of relates back to a
couple of things we've already touched
on.
>> One was when you were talking about
maybe you're in a difficult conversation
before you start reacting and just
blurting out words,
>> right?
>> You're saying that first word is your
breath. Okay. So, you're what is that an
inhale?
>> Yeah. So, it's um you would know this as
a physiological sigh. It's where it's a
double inhalation where it's about 3
seconds in through your nose, 2 seconds
in again at the top,
>> and then all out through your nose
again. Now, we can do that in a sense of
very exaggerated. I'm not not talking
about the sigh of like what my
5-year-old would do of like uh like not
not that type of not that type of
breath,
>> but you want to be able to use it and
you can do it silently anytime right
before you say something that you need
to catch a moment or if somebody's
saying something that's you can tell
you're it's you don't like and you're
getting worked up. You ever heard
somebody like making an opinion or
saying something you don't like and what
happens? you our bodies go like we we
everything we don't like it we kind of
start to seize up we start we take a big
breath we're like okay I don't I'm I
don't I got to I got to get ready cuz
why we're about ready to unleash all of
our our words
>> and so when you hold your breath that's
why your breath has really nowhere to go
except to yell
>> often it it decreases communication the
same way of you know how
uh at least if you're trying to find
directions and you're trying to find a
house and you have blaring music, you
have to like turn down the music so you
can you're like, "Let me turn down this
music so I can see." It's kind of that
same mentality of when somebody's
yelling, you can't really listen.
>> Yeah. It's it's this whole we see the
world through the state of our nervous
system, right? That person said that
thing that you didn't like and if you
start to react and hold your breath,
which may be understandable, right?
>> You're changing the state of your
nervous system. So everything is coming
inward. Your focus is coming inward. who
are getting prepared to fight. So of
course
>> the next words you say
>> are going to come out with a certain
energy. So I love that sort of idea that
you make it and you you know that whole
section that in in that chapter you do
sort of walk people through how you can
practice this breath
>> and get to the point whereby you're
doing it naturally in conversation where
the person doesn't even know that you're
doing it.
>> Yeah. Abs. And I'm happy to do it right
now if you want to.
>> All right. So, if you're listening right
now, let's let's let's practice this. I
call this a conversational breath and
it's a breath that you can use and
nobody's really going to know that
you're doing it. It's there's nothing
special. It's just the it's the choice
to be intentional with your breath and
let's do it together. So, it's all going
to be through your nose and it's going
to be a double inhale. Meaning, we're
going to inhale twice. Ready? So, if
you're listening, we're going to go 3
seconds in through your nose, two more
at the top, and then all out through
your nose.
Now, just listening to us right now,
your shoulder should have dropped just a
little bit. You're going to feel just a
little bit calmer. That's your go-to
when somebody is saying something you
don't like or uh you're about to
respond. So, right now, I want you,
Ranga, to continue to do the
conversational breath, and I'm going to
continue to say some things to you. So,
I Yes, I understand you have a podcast,
and yeah, it's a health podcast. In
fact, it's the number one health podcast
in the world, but you know what? I don't
know if you're doing as well as you need
to. I mean, you could be these lights.
Have you seen these cameras? I don't
know if I even really like these these
microphones. Now, see, as you're talking
to me right now, I see I didn't even
realize that you're breathing any
differently than anybody else. And so,
anytime somebody's saying something
that's agitating to you in that sense,
it's allowing you to see the depth,
right? It's allowing you to see the
cause rather than getting worked up and
holding your breath to fight the
symptoms.
>> Yeah. It's it's amazing because you're
you're slowing everything down, right?
So, you know, using that analogy being
in the car again. Yeah.
>> Um, if your car is going fast,
>> you're not going to be able to take
everything in, right? Because
everything's going back quickly. You
slow down your car and go down the
street,
>> you can suddenly see everything clearly.
I saw that number. I saw that number.
You know, that's what going there's a
cat coming. Whatever it might be, right?
So, when we slow everything down,
>> our perspective is different. We see
more clearly. So, clearly in a
conversation,
>> Yes. especially a conversation that
perhaps isn't going the way that you
want it to,
>> right?
>> If you're able to slow things down,
>> yes,
>> you're going to be more present, you're
going to, you know, you're going to have
that separation between the stimulus,
the words you don't like, and the
response you're about to give. Exactly.
Time has a way of sifting out priority.
We all know, we've had these moments and
conversations that feel really intense
with that friend at the cafe. the next
day, you know what? That conversation
really didn't matter all that much.
>> Or a week goes by and you go, why did I
ever react that way?
>> But in the moment, you felt that it did.
>> In the moment, it was everything. And
then or you get that email, you read
that email at work and you want to it
gets you all worked up and you're ready
to send that that nasty response back,
but something happens and you go, you
know what? I'm just going to I'm just
going to put this down. You read it
again the next day.
>> You that's not even worth my response.
>> Exactly. That that's the power of
silence.
>> Can you tell if somebody is going to be
a high performer or going to be
successful based on the way that they
communicate?
>> A thousand%. And I'll tell you the
biggest key is their pace. How fast or
slow they respond. If you ask me a
question or let's say I'm interviewing
and you ask me an important interview
question and I immediately respond,
yeah, that's probably true. You know, I
thinking and again this is in my
experience and I'm just
what it's indicating is I didn't really
listen all the way because it's possible
I missed
>> the lowhanging fruit. I miss the whole
point of this because it's not just the
experience in the words. It's how you
handle the present
>> versus if you ask me a question and all
of a sudden all of a sudden I went
>> in my experience and then I went on and
I slowed down my words. All it says is I
am controlled.
>> I'm not emotionally reactive.
>> It's the same people that and this is
not to step on anybody's toes. If you
cuss in every other sentence, what you
really indicate is I am emotionally
sensitive.
>> It's I I'm overseeing my food. I don't
have any other words to explain how I'm
feeling or what I'm doing. So, I just
expect that throwing
a curse word right in front of it is
going to make it more impactful in some
way, but it also dilutes the message
>> because that's not what anybody hears.
So, it's kind of that same exact
concept. The pace of your conversation,
the difference between
if I I was going to say, "I already told
you I'm not going to do that, Cody. I
already told you I'm not going to do
that." versus, "I already told you I'm
not going to do that." Like, that right
there is who sounds more in control? Who
sounds like they can be relied upon? Who
sounds like this is a person who knows
what's happening?
>> Who sounds like the person who's cannot
be moved? It's always the slower.
>> How do you work on your inflection in
order for people to take you seriously?
Because you have incredible pacing,
inflection, presence, eye contact.
>> That is hard, I think, for a lot of
people to do. What advice would you give
somebody who doesn't think too much
about the way they say things? uh but
only things about what they say.
>> Oh, that's a good question. Number one
is you want to use a tone that goes
down. So if you pictured it for my
listening, if you pictured it on a
graph, you want to start at like a five
and then you kind of go down to it too.
>> So you use it in a tone of let's say
like at the table and I ask I was going
to ask you to pass me the salt. I
wouldn't say, "Can you pass me the
salt?" as if like you don't know what it
is.
>> I'm going to say, "Can you pass me the
salt?" So, you're going down with it.
Every time person who goes up on the
inflection, it sounds a lot more
uh uncertain, unsure. So, you want to
kind of end downward and slow your words
down. Two, for eye contact. And I know
we have a mutual friend, Vanessa. I know
she also talks about this. People are
much more forgiving if you don't keep
eye contact eye contact the whole time.
You can look around, but as long as you
end the last bit of your sentence with
eye contact, nobody will know the
difference.
>> Oh, interesting.
>> Yeah. So, if you I have people when I
trained um teach every one of my clients
for deposition. I'll say, "Look, this
video it's going to be recorded." So, I
want you to try and end all of your
sentences looking forward so it doesn't
look like you're looking all over the
place because when you do, then it looks
like you're trying to hide or worse,
don't look at me. Anytime you get a
question, don't go uh and look at me.
Don't do that. So, I need you to keep
looking. And it's I can look all around
this room, but it's not to the very end
of my contact,
>> the end of that sentence that I make
that eye contact, you'll never feel like
anything else is is different. But three
would be the slower your words come out,
the more intentional they sound. And you
don't want to use the filler words, the
ums, the a's. It's fine for everyday
communication. If you and I want to um
all it up,
>> we can knock ourselves out. Nobody
cares. But when you need that high
performance communication, you need to
get rid of all the filler words that
water down your sentences and just serve
them neat.
>> Yeah. It's interesting because
like I'm doing it right now. When I'm
thinking about something, I don't
typically have eye contact because I'm
usually listening when I have eye
contact. It's something I have to work
on quite a bit. Actually, when I'm
really pondering something, I look up or
I look down in order to get my words
correctly. But it's interesting. And I
wouldn't ever end that way. I would
always start that way. So maybe
naturally I got lucky with that one.
>> Um but the um ability to
speak quickly without filler words I
think is super important.
[clears throat]
>> Um you talk smoothly. I wouldn't say you
talk slow though. I I guess I suppose as
opposed to a lot of people including me,
you talk slower,
>> right? But there is also a real fine
line between somebody who doesn't
communicate concisely
>> and somebody who communicates concisely
but slowly. So if somebody's listening
to this, how do they determine, hey, I'm
just talking sm uh smooth but slow
versus I'm just talking too slow and not
getting to the point.
>> Oh, we usually can tell that by the
frustration of the other person.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> The feedback.
>> Yeah. the other person will start doing
what we talked about. You start popping
your knuckles and breathing out your
nose and getting frustrated because it's
creating that anxiety in the in the
conversation whenever you're you're
doing that. I I think that everybody
right now at this this point of our
life, we really are searching for calm
energy. You you want a leader to lead,
they have calm energy. The the high
performers, the people who are relied
upon, they say, "You know what? I know
that Cody is she knows what she's doing.
Oh, I don't know what's going on. Thank
goodness Cody does. It's because of the
calm energy. You think of any movie
you've seen or you think of anybody in
combat, it's the leaders have the calm
energy. They do not respond emotionally
to the chaos. And those are the people
that people look to and they look for
that in everyday conversation. There's a
reason why when you go into your
grandmother's house, all of a sudden you
feel at ease. M
>> it's that calm energy that says don't
worry honey you're good tell me all
about it when you have this sense of you
go into one of my favorite restaurants
is this mom and pop she calls everybody
honey calls everybody darling sweetie
it's like yes I just love we need that
we really do more than you think we need
that calm energy
>> when you're around these people that are
always anxious always go go go always
want to just you got to
>> 10x everything about your life like that
is that's a quick way to being really
unsatisfied
>> yeah with a lot of lot of things.
There's nothing wrong with talking slow.
>> I would say people say I talk slower in
person than I do in my videos because
I'm not having to cram
>> everything in 47 seconds.
>> Um, but it's it's this calm energy that
that people are drawn to like a moth to
a flame because it's this vibe that you
when you can come into the room and they
go, "Oh, thank goodness they're here."
like all of a sudden it's this everybody
at the room feels different by your
presence and it's not because you're
hyping everybody up. That's great.
There's a place for that. That is not
sustainable.
>> It's the calm energy that leaders show
that means they always know that they're
captain of the ship.
>> Fascinating. So, I'm sure there are many
times where you feel super anxious and
you feel elevated and you do not feel
like the grounding energy. In fact,
you'd love somebody else to be that,
>> right? What do you do to prepare
yourself to be that calm in the storm?
Is there something that you do to
regground yourself so when you walk in
the door to your family? Yeah.
>> You're different,
>> right? Well, biggest key is I I I really
do try to be exactly who I am at home,
same at work, but you have to wear a
different hat. Like I get it.
>> It's this and it's it's rule number one
in the book of Sate with Control.
>> Let your breath be the first word that
you say. And I teach it to every one of
my clients before they answer a
question. And when somebody's asking
them a question they don't like and I
take my own medicine. I do the very same
thing with and when an opposing attorney
is saying something I don't like, you
better believe I'm using my breath to
make sure I'm contin continually uh
regulating my system.
>> Yeah.
>> When that's all happening. Otherwise,
you I'm bad at holding my breath.
>> That's what happens, Cody. I I I'll hold
my breath in moments of tension. Mhm.
>> And then all of a sudden I realize, why
does my body feel like I'm drowning?
>> Well, it's because you are. I mean,
you're you're you're preventing oxygen
from flowing. That's why everything is
tight. And that's why you yell
>> cuz your your body goes, "I don't know
what to do with all this trapped air we
got. So, we better just
>> shoot it out." It's because you just
>> put it like a in a bottle and shook it
up.
>> Just waiting for it to to pop. But when
you breathe the entire time, it's like
breathing underwater. you can put me as
deep as I need to go. I'm I'm still all
right. Interesting.
>> Uh no matter what the pressure is. So,
it's it's a lot of the letting your
breath be the first word that you say.
So, wherever a your first word would be
>> before you say the I don't agree with
that or the that's not true, you put a
breath. And what it does is it allows
your logical analytical side to stay at
the forefront where you don't get
emotionally swept. And the benefit is so
does that other person. Yes,
>> that's what happens when we talk about
the how do you handle insults. When you
allow that five to seven seconds, what
often happens is that other person will
all of a sudden their logical side will
come up and go, "No, no, no. That's not
what I want to say." And they will
apologize as soon as they said it.
>> That's not what I meant to say. I
shouldn't have said that. What I meant
to say was and they'll adjust it because
they realize they can hear it now. It's
not what they want to put off.
>> Yeah. [sighs]
You know what's interesting is um this
is so good for negotiation, too. You
talk a lot about just communication and
conversations in general, but so much of
this it just reminds me of a mixture of
like Robert Green and also Chris Voss
and Yeah.
>> Have you talked to Chris yet?
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah. He's got You guys have that
same voice, too. Like, has he done his
radio operator voice for you yet?
>> Oh, yeah, of course. [laughter] Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
>> Is that like step one?
>> Yeah. Oh my goodness. And his stuff is
uh mine I I guess we came at a totally
different ways and mine's more of this
like good old country, you know,
whatever. and his is this more northern
>> vibe mob boss type of like he could he
could he could convince me to give you
me to like give him my couch while I sit
on it like that's just what his voice
can do. So I I'm very curious what the
actual statistics would be about the
important importance of voice.
>> Oh, it's got to be high.
>> It has to be so high of what it does
because he would be like I agree that's
a it is a great couch. like I just I
need your couch. Like [laughter] dang.
All right.
>> He seems like he needs it. I Well, you
know what's funny is him in particular,
I think I've learned a ton from watching
his stuff and people are going to learn
so much from reading your book because I
one of my favorite mentors of all time
said, uh, if you're not capable of
having difficult conversations to the
point where you start to enjoy them
because you learn from them, you'll
probably never be very successful.
>> Oh, yeah. That's good.
>> That's very true. I love that.
>> I think it is true. It's the more that
you can learn. You say it somewhere. You
say something along the lines of um it's
an opportunity to uncover.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It it's this idea that if
you want to have a deeper relationship,
then you have to have a deeper tolerance
for difficult conversations. Like if you
only want to have surface level
conversations, well, I'll show you a
surface level relationship. You're not
going to be able to go deep. Like you
you and your husband have had some
probably the toughest conversations. out
of that you have the closest bond.
People that have gone through the
hardest moments together and come out of
it will always be stronger. So it's this
idea that if you shun difficult
conversations,
life is not going to be any easier. It's
not it's not the way it works. It's
almost it's the opposite. If you enjoyed
that clip and want to see the rest of
the conversation, you can click right
here. Or if you want to see the latest
episode of the Jefferson Fisher podcast,
click right here and I'll meet you